Sie arbeiten hier illegal und ohne Schutz, um nicht zu hungern.
Es ist stickig, es ist heiß. Und die Wände könnten jederzeit einstürzen.
Und es sind nicht nur Erwachsene, die hier arbeiten, sondern auch Kinder.
Das sind Bilder aus Indien. Das ist über 7.000 Kilometer weit weg.
Trotzdem hat es etwas mit uns zu tun.
Es ist die dunkle Seite davon, was uns so schön schimmern lässt.
Das Glimmermineral Mica ist ein wichtiger Rohstoff für richtig viele Kosmetikprodukte.
Es lässt Highlighter, Lippenstift und Nagellack so schön funkeln.
Wie kann es sein, dass Kinder den Preis dafür zahlen und was wird dagegen getan?
Sie sind zwischen sechs und acht und sie sammeln sonntags Mica
in einem der ärmsten Staaten Indiens. In Jharkhand.
Das ist illegal, aber sie sind bei weitem nicht allein.
Terre des Hommes schätzt, dass etwa 22.000 Kinder in Indien Mica schürfen,
statt in die Schule zu gehen. Den meisten Konzernen, die den Rohstoff verwenden,
von Chemie- über Kosmetik- bis hin zu Autoherstellern ist das Problem bekannt.
Sie wollen etwas tun, doch eine echte Lösung ist nicht wirklich in Sicht.
Das Glitzermineral kommt auf der ganz Welt vor. Aber etwa 30 Prozent des Glimmers,
der nach Europa kommt, stammt aus Indien. Und zwar zu 90% aus einem Teil,
in dem der Rohstoff offiziell gar nicht abgebaut werden darf.
Jharkand und Bihar gehören zu den Ärmsten Regionen Indiens
und genau hier liegt der Glimmergürtel.
Seit 1980 ist dort der Abbau aus Naturschutzgründen offiziell zwar verboten –
geht aber trotzdem weiter.
Denn Mica ist dort quasi die einzige Möglichkeit, Geld zu verdienen.
Jetzt läuft der Abbau in der Region komplett illegal in hunderten kleinen Stollen.
Dort arbeiten dann ganze Familien. Sie sprengen sich teilweise in den Berg
oder sammeln Mica an der Oberfläche. Und die Arbeit ist gefährlich.
Der Staub macht krank und immer wieder brechen Stollen ein,
es kommt zu schweren Verletzungen und Todesfällen.
In der Region bezahlen pro Monat etwa 12 Menschen den Job mit ihrem Leben.
Anita Devi hat bei einem Grubenunglück ihren Mann verloren.
Seither muss sie vier Kinder alleine versorgen.
Sowohl der Abbau als auch Kinderarbeit in Minen sind offiziell verboten,
aber die Kontrollen schrecken nicht wirklich ab.
Damit das Mica dann international verkauft werden kann,
wandert es durch diverse Zwischenhändler. An erster Stelle stehen die kleine Sammelstellen.
Und danach verwischen recht schnell die Spuren. Zwischenhändler kaufen sich
offizielle Zertifikate wie diese, um das Mica reinzuwaschen.
Dann stammt der Rohstoff offiziell aus legalen Minen in Rajasthan
und ist zu 100% ohne Kinderarbeit abgebaut worden. So ist es bereit zum Export,
denn viele große Unternehmen auch in Europa bestehen auf den Zertifikaten.
Die kosten zwar, aber das Geschäft ist lukrativ genug.
Das ist alles seit Jahren bekannt. Spätestens jedoch seit 2016.
Da gab es diverse Berichte über die Zustände vor Ort.
Seither hat sich ein bisschen was getan, aber das Problem bleibt.
Die indische Regierung hat 2017 sogar angekündigt, den Abbau zu legalisieren,
damit man ihn besser kontrollieren kann. Geschehen ist bisher nicht viel.
Eine traurige Folge der Berichte ist, dass die Geschäfte teilweise
noch stärker vertuscht werden. Und dass Unfälle noch seltener gemeldet werden –
aus Angst vor Konsequenzen. Aber, gleichzeitig hat die Berichterstattung
auch den Druck auf viele Konzerne erhöht. Etwa 50 Konzerne haben sich seit 2017
zu einer NGO zusammengeschlossen, die die Kinderarbeit bis 2022 auslöschen will.
Auch durch konsequente Nachverfolgung. Die Unternehmen wissen jetzt also,
dass aktuell Kinder für den Rohstoff arbeiten. Aber den Import stoppen,
sollen sie laut der NGO aber nicht.
Das wird also dauern. Denn dafür braucht es einen Strukturwandel in der Region.
Und bis dahin? Wie gut lassen sich die Lieferanten kontrollieren?
Der Chemieriese Merck zum Beispiel gehört zu den großen Abnehmern und betont,
es gebe null Toleranz gegenüber Kinderarbeit. Dafür würden eigene Kontrollen sorgen.
In der Realität lässt es sich jedoch kaum garantieren und sieht wohl auch so aus:
Das Beispiel zeigt mal wieder, wie schwierig es den Konzernen fällt,
ihre weltweiten und verschachtelten Lieferketten zu kontrollieren.
Zudem verlassen viele Unternehmen nach wie vor auf die staatlichen
Zertifikate und Kontrollen, von den wir ja jetzt wissen,
dass sie oft auch nicht standhalten. Deshalb ist jetzt auch die Frage:
Was können wir Verbraucher tun? Und die ist leider gar nicht so leicht zu beantworten.
Denn Mica ist in so vielen Produkten, dass wir es gar nicht wirklich vermeiden können.
Wenn ich durch meine alltäglichen Kosmetikprodukte gehe, ist Mica
in fast allen Produkten drin. Deklariert entweder als MICA oder als CI 77019.
Schaut mal bei euren Sachen nach.
Und das sind nur die Kosmetik-Produkte. Daneben ist es in Autolack
und ganz vielen Elektronik-Produkten.
Weil die Lieferwege so undurchsichtig sind, ist es für uns Verbraucher
fast unmöglich, herauszufinden, ob Kinderarbeit in den Produkten steckt.
Was sollen wir also jetzt tun? Terre des Hommes empfiehlt drei Dinge:
Wir können auf jeden Fall nachfragen. Bei den Unternehmen und den Herstellern
und damit das Bewusstsein und den Druck erhöhen. Und dafür sorgen,
dass sie mehr Transparenz bieten und auch einfordern.
Außerdem gibt es Organisationen, die sich vor Ort gegen Kinderarbeit engagieren.
Die kann man unterstützen.
Oder man kann sich dafür einsetzen, dass zum Beispiel die deutsche Regierung dafür sorgt,
dass Unternehmen mehr Verantwortung entlang der Lieferkette übernehmen müssen.
Und es nicht nur in den Broschüren und auf den Homepages steht.
Aber was auch klar ist:
solange die Zwischenhändler vor Ort damit ein so gutes Geschäft machen
und die Menschen vor Ort keine Alternativen haben,
wird sich vermutlich nicht so schnell etwas ändern.
Komplett transparente Lieferketten sind aktuell utopisch.
Und so müssen sich entlang der ganzen Produktion von der Mine bis hin zu uns Verbrauchern
alle der Verantwortung bewusst sein: Es könnten immer Kinder daran gearbeitet haben.
Schön, dass ihr zugeschaut habt und sogar nach dem Jingle noch da seid.
Bei so viel Motivation würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr mir mal unten in die Kommentare schreibt,
mit welchem Thema wir uns dieses Jahr noch beschäftigen sollten.